by a vote of four to zero Natalie Eve
Marie you are evicted from the Big
Brother house all right Natalie sad to
see you here they finally broke up you
and Lolo what happened why are you the
one that had to go
I think multiple reasons one kandi and
Dina were going to vote for me no matter
what kandi already let me know that I
was her biggest threat and then I did
not want it to come down to a split
decision and give Tom green any more
power so I kind of knew hence why I was
in an athletic clothes I was ready I was
ready for it yeah you could kind of tell
during your plea slash goodbye speech
that you knew this was the night that
you were headed out the door yes double
eviction night though um yes a whole
round a big brother happened after you
left you don't know what happened though
I was waiting for the celebrity twist
saying not only Eva Marie you are back
in the house I know it seems like we
were gonna get that decided it was like
stay there I don't find out I was like
Julie you girl come through but no all
right you want to know what happened
your left all right so there was that
safety car okay who want Tamar wins the
safety car nice nice nice okay then HOH
yeah lo lo Wednesday Charla oh my god
not the feel later Tom it's been nice
knowing you buddy okay so she nominates
Tom Canty yes boom that's my girl that
is what I'm talking about
Lolo you get a girl yes all right
oh my god then power of veto happens
Tamar wins POV oh my god
nominations say the same see ya
nominations stay the same tom is coming
in here next oh my gosh they did it damn
and I'm out here is that what you wanted
to see happen I think it is sorry tom
it's been fun but it was your time to go
as well kind of a nice silver lining on
this night you're out Wow Wow Wow
Wow that is like so amazing I feel
really good about going like so
peacefully I guess you can say let's
talk about your game okay let's talk
about it
you played big brother and you played it
hard I did huh what would you have done
differently though honestly I think that
is why I am so at peace with standing in
front of you right now at this very
moment is I don't really think that I
would have switched anything because
it's one of those things it's a game
time decision at that moment at that
time looking back my only regret is I
could have won the HOH the dice
tumblin dice that's gonna haunt me
forever that one and I could have won
the veto and then I want to be standing
in front of you other than that I played
a solid game and some of the chips just
didn't fall my way but that's big
brother
expect the unexpected that's right what
surprised you the most about this
experience um I think my mental
toughness is off the chain I feel like I
can go and take on anything in the world
I've had my own personal trials and
tribulations that people have were able
to see during the show as well however I
never like had any type of breakdown
moment because if you think about it
you're in there you're by yourself you
don't have any type of outlet that you
normally do in the real life meaning
phone books parents husbands wives
friends to basically bounce off like oh
my god I'm having a bad day talk to me
like talk me down you don't have any of
that and I was able to like I'm sad that
I'm not there but I could go another 30
days or sick I could do it I could do
regular big brother let's go I was gonna
say could we get you in there for a
whole 90 days I think the people would
want it that would be interesting to put
somebody who played celebi be in a
regular season CBS you heard it first
let's go now you made a friend for life
in this house it seems like with lolo
did you make other friends for life in
this game i don't know i'm gonna have to
watch this season and then we'll see
because trust me i already know how it
is and i'm sure a lot of people said a
lot of
and then I get to watch it back and then
be like girl what but I'm pretty sure
that Lolo for sure rode with me til the
end like I did with her
you've got five days to this finale I
was five days away are you gonna go home
and cram watch everything so that you
have all the knowledge in the world to
cast your vote that night well
considering I lived it and I only really
am missing tonight that went down and it
went exactly how I hoped for it to go
that's gonna be a game-time decision I
don't know if I'm gonna cram it or not
because I kind of want to go based off
how I lived it as opposed to how its
kind of edited okay do you know what I'm
saying
yeah I can appreciate that I think some
fans can appreciate that yeah I think so
because I was in there with these people
and I want to be able to really base it
on on everything their game play I'm the
type that I want to see somebody that
wins well hopefully low in
but I also want to see somebody that
wins that is going in there and playing
the game not just sitting back and like
crossing their fingers and hoping that
they kind of like it's good and along
the way so that's I think as of right
now I have a lot of emotions because I
just left the Big Brother house so I'm
smelling fresh air for the first time
but I I don't I think that I'm going to
cast my vote in the end but we'll see
you are a free woman in a couple minutes
once this interview is done what's the
first thing you're gonna do when we let
chat those doors back into the real
world kiss my husband and hug him and
tell him that I absolutely love him and
appreciate him and realize like wow I am
so lucky if you had to sum up your Big
Brother experience in one word what's
your word okay I have to sure I'll give
you two yes got it well actually I
needed a little an mark but everything
and more okay so it's everything you
expected it to be awesome best
experience ever
i hands-down cannot thank CVS enough I
cannot thank the entire production the
crew I mean do you guys look at these
sets
hello that is a lot of time and energy
and we are doing these sets in like
record time because the regular Big
Brother is 99 days yeah hi we're here 30
so it's like a torture its warp speed
so I mean honestly I I can't thank the
entire crew at CBS enough because this
was an experience of a lifetime I have
learned something that I'm going to
cherish forever not only about myself
but about other people and just like wow
I'm just really really impressed at how
amazing of an experience that I have had
and I'm gonna remember it forever we'll
leave it on that note that nice positive
note
[Music]